the decision to approve the budget today
is um it will mean so much for the
future high streets funds it means that
we can now take forward all elements of
the project
and deliver the market quarter
we now have to go to expectation stages
which is next and and the amendment that
we made today means that we can include
the public as much as we possibly can
moving forward which is really important
there's been some really interesting
stuff put forward by members of the
community and as to how they see that
working for them and obviously they are
the users so that's really important to
um
bring that in to the discussions um
we'll be talking to the design teams now
we'll be putting forward things to
planning and this is where we can really
start to get some engagement on how that
space will work and what's going to be
in it 9.2
million pounds it forms part of a larger
package of money in total that's in in
terms of the investment coming into
newton now but so it's going to really
mean a lot not just to newton abbott
actually but to people that live in the
surrounding towns like myself that come
into newton abbott to sharpen kind of
chill um
the the future will mean that there's
more things to see and do and engage
with when we're there and hopefully
we'll be able to retain some of our
young people with the skills that
they've got in the performing arts and
other things into staying here the
future of the markets is really
important to this redevelopment we've
got
lots of market traders who
are
affected in terms of what will happen to
that space and they'll have a
revitalized market area and be able to
generate a better offer
and other
young people or um other businesses
should be attracted in to that and their
footfall is currently decreasing so that
will see
a potential increase in footfall
into the markets area bringing a new
vibrancy to the town because where
people come they're more likely to look
spend money elsewhere as well